[Applaudissements]
il était une fois une petite ville où
les gens étaient comme pris au piège
mais une fille était différente il me
faut vraiment ce job je peux rien y
faire on lui disait qu'elle ne pourrait
jamais partir comment elle sa fille a
alors
tu es sûr que tu veux le faire les
heures
il y avait un jeu
qu'on appelait panique cette année le
gagnant remportera 50000 dollars tous
les ans de nouveaux joueurs s'affrontent
relève de nouveaux défis
tu n'as pas besoin de panique pour aller
à la fac apparemment si tu as tout pour
gagner mais soient prudentes
l'an dernier on a perdu deux gamins à
cause de cieux mais on va trouver le
responsable regardez ça
[Musique]
ça commence
bienvenue dans panique
premier défi traverser la manche l'unss
au jeu
chaque joueur a sa propre histoire t'as
jamais peur tout le monde a peur de
quelque chose
chaque joueur cache quelque chose toi et
moi on peut gagner ensemble
oh
je crois qu'il ya un tricheur
ces jeux sont organisés par des juges on
sait pas vraiment qui y sont
[Musique]
des mois la vérité pourquoi est ce que
tu veux
il faut savoir de quoi avoir peur
à quel moment avoir peur et savoir faire
la différence
il était une fois une ville bâtie sur
des mensonges
s'il vous plaît
non plus tout